Hãy bỏng sẵn của bảo hiểm só hội Việt Nam, khách nhóm chuyện tụi động chực tiếp của mục tiết của mục tiết,
bình chức người đồng trong đơn vị sự nghiệp công lập.
Được lượng vũ trang và một số đối tượng hưởng lương từ ngăn sách,
mới đồng tí tục đồng tảng phần trang vào cuối hư chiến tự vất,
và một phẩy năm phần trang vào cuối bảo hiểm ý tế.
Đối với người tham gia bảo hiểm só hội tình huyện,
bất tuy nhiệp tối ra làm khăn cử động tăng từ bố mi sống chiệu,
tảng trang nghiệp đồng.
Lên năm mi chèo xong trong nghìn đồng mối tháng,
bữa đồng hình mi tế của nhiều nhóm đối tượng,
tính theo lương cơ sở,
cũng bây giờ điều trình lên một trăm mười bàng nghiệp tảng trong năm mối tháng,
chú khi đó các nhóm đình nâng sách nhảnh nó hỗ trợ,
hoặc đống và gộ bảo hiểm ý tế,
và đường bảo đồng quyền lời thật quy định.
Bây tăng hương cơ sở không chỉ làm thay đổi mức đồng bảo hiểm,
mà còn gấp phần năng mức hưởng của nhiều chiến sách ăn sình xá hội.